And then start by. Welcome to the DDPS seminar
everyone. Before we introduce our invited
speaker, let's go over some rules and logistics.
First, please mute yourself during the talk.
But if you have questions, you can unmute
and ask your questions. We'll use chatroom
to post your questions so that we can address
them in the q&a session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to external audiences.
Therefore, no classified discussion is allowed.
Finally, the talk today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now let me introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Dr. mango grove who
is an assistant professor in applied mathematics
at the University of Twente the Netherlands.
Prior to this appointment, he held postdoctoral
positions at EPFL Institute of mathematics
and the Odin Institute for computational engineering
and sciences at UT Austin. He received his
bachelor's in engineering and PhD degrees
in civil engineering, both with top honors
from Tsinghua University in 2013, and 2017.
His research interests spanned several areas
areas areas, in computational engineering
sciences, of course, exciting areas, including
boulder with sand, we UQ, multi fidelity data
fusion and probabilistic methods for scientific
machine learning. Currently, he receives a
financial support from Dutch National Instruments,
sec to plan data on the Focus Area mathematics
of computational science today, man who will
present an exciting topic, which is probabilistic
methods for data driven, reduced order modelling.
I'm sure we will hear an exciting talk today
but before I pass the baton to man, oh, let
me ask a couple of questions to him just to
get to know him better and make this seminar
somewhat informal. Okay, first question here
people. In your bio, you have listed several
research interests like model reduction, UQ,
multi fidelity, data, fusion and probabilistic
methods for scientific machine learning, etc.
Yeah, I know they are all related. But if
you have to choose one, that is the most exciting
to you right now. What what is it? And why?
If I have to choose that I don't prefer but
if I had to choose, I would choose UQ. I think
especially in the current year of scientific
machine learning UQ is a cross section right
across scientific computing, computational
statistics, machine learning, physics based
simulation and DDPS. Right, that I think the
crossroad is UQ. And the most excited about
it. I'm also teaching UQ to the masters students,
and they are also quite interested in UQ topics.
Yeah,
awesome. Awesome. I guess you're going to
say I'm UK conference next
year. Yeah, indeed, is a very nice city. Yeah.
I will see you there. Then. Second question,
here we go. I always like being a professor
at the University of Twente the Netherlands,
if I give you a minute to advertise your university
here to audiences, how owes you brag about
your school?
Yeah, this is a very international university
is in inside the Netherlands is in the middle
of Europe. But all of our teaching, no matter
a bachelor level, or master level, everything
is in English. So we have a variety of students
from all the countries you can think of. And
the diversity and inclusion is perfect here.
So I welcome a lot of students from from us,
and from China, from other countries, to our
university to have bachelor or master's studies,
or PhDs. And this is definitely one of the
best environments you can get in Europe for
International Studies and Research. Awesome.
Sounds
wonderful. All right. The stage is yours.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you for the invitation,
nice questions and introduction. And I value
this very good opportunity to share some of
our risk research results on probabilistic
methods for data driven reuse on modeling,
some established resort results and some more
recent results. I often like to start my motivation
by talking a little bit about digital twin
and technologies in our digital twin is currently
a very trendy topic in the computational engineering
community. And when we talk about digital
twin, we're actually referring to digital
replicas that persistently represents a unique
physical asset throughout its lifecycle, powered
by Big Data and enabled by a dynamical synchronization
between the physical and the digital twins.
And in my personal opinion, the success of
digital training with highly rely on the synergistic
integration of basics based modeling and machine
learning together with real world observational
data and this is actually perfectly aligned
with as the spirit of scientific machine learning
and the order to realize the dynamical real
time synchronization between the physical
and digital twins, it is crucial to realize
to enable a multiplayer way real time simulations.
As I guess most of you already know in scientific
computing, multivariate real time simulations
are often described by a nonlinear time dependence,
possibly also parametric partial differential
equations. If we use full order solvers with
detailed code to solve this multi query real
time problems, it may result to prohibitive
or computational cost. And this is why and
aware I reduce all the modeling comes into
the stage right. So generally speaking, model
reduction or reduce all the modeling attempts
to intelligently reduce the system complexity
by representing high dimensional physical
systems in low dimensional latent spaces,
just in case some of the audience may not
be perfectly familiar with model reduction.
Just a few words about the general spirit
of reduced order modeling, I'm summarizing
the typical framework for model reduction
into three R's reduce represent and recover.
So, typically, in the first step, we reduce
a high dimensional solution manifold into
a low dimensional latent space and inside
such a latent space, we represent our physical
system in a low dimensionality forming forming
our reduced order system and solve along with
it. Once we have solved the reduced the stays
and in the last step, we can recover or decoded
back to the full order size, right this is
a three step methodology reduce represent
and recover. In my personal opinion, the most
tricky part is often the second step the representation
of the system insights a low dimensionality
our latent space, a classical treatment for
as his representation is through coloring
or Petrov Galerkin projection, we just a project
the full order systems into into the reduced
latent space right. And this classical and
conventional treatment through projection
or record projection based model reduction
is often intrusive, meaning that we have to
get the access to the inside of the food order
code to extract the matrixes or vectors or
whatever elements we may need to formulate
our reducer the system and the product numerical
projection will also be problem dependent
and this intrusive nature will most possibly
result in a limited industrial relevance,
which is not something we want and this has
been my and also many other colleagues motivation
to develop data driven reduce all the models
yeah nine intrusive manner, the holy grail
in this area is to find is to learn physically
consistent representations of reduced order
dynamics primarily from data instead of numerical
projections to formulate or reduce other systems.
So here I'm quoting arbitrage nine, as far
as the laws of mathematics refer to reality
is they are not certain and and as far as
they are certain they do not refer to reality.
So basically, this has emphasized is it has
pointed out the importance of uncertainty
quantification in scientific discovery and
physical simulations. And of course, when
we do data driven model reduction or non intrusive
manner, when we do the learning process, it
is inevitable to encounter noise in the data
as well as a variety of uncertainties throughout
the modeling process, and this has been my
motivation to use probabilistic machine learning
to facilitate Our data driven reduce all the
models with a net natural uncertainty quantification,
and the in the upcoming perhaps 40 ish minutes,
I'm going to briefly review some of our research
efforts in the last five, six years until
very recent. There are three classes of methods
I would like to discuss, depending on how
much physics we are incorporating into the
models, we have the first method being blackbox
method, basically using Gaussian process surrogate
models to build reduce all the models. And
the second method is a gray box method, we
try to represent reduce all the dynamical
systems with a probabilistic learning technique
called the deep kernel learning. And the last
but not least, we are going to discuss a third
method, a glass box method using Bayesian
inference to estimate reduced order operators.
Okay, so my journey along this path started
roughly five, six years ago in Switzerland,
and we started with Gaussian process surrogate
modeling, and this method is no longer new.
And maybe it's not that exactly exciting anymore,
but it did set basis for a lot of follow up
considerations in the other method I'm going
to introduce, so, here I would still like
to briefly discuss this method a little bit
and also introduce our critical numerical
tool with Gaussian process emulation, which
will be also used in the other two methods
in different ways. Okay. So, we started with
a very, very simple and straightforward idea,
the reduce or the modeling often seeks to
find a low rank approximation of the reduced
order solutions. So the reduced order solutions
will be spacetime parameter dependent and
it is actually represented as a linear combination
of a small number of reduced basis vectors
over space with time parameter combination
coefficients, right and to be ordered together
reduce basis vectors, we can use unsupervised
learning, basically, dimensionality reduction.
And the most popular method, as you know,
is linear PCA or we call it proper orthogonal
decomposition in the model reduction community,
we just get the full order snapshot solution
data and the Compress through linear PCA and
get our reduced basis vectors. And then the
question is about how to approximate the time
parameter dependent combination coefficients.
And here we are using a very simple tool we
are using regression to to approximate the
map from the time parameter inputs onto the
projection coefficients onto the onto the
reduced basis and use this regression model
as a surrogate for our expansion coefficients
of the pod and bases right. So one step of
unsupervised learning and another step of
supervised learning and after the training
in the offline stage, the online stage is
simulation free, we just need to evaluate
the regression output class simple linear
combination of the reduced basis right. And
you order to further improvement the offline
training stage we also try the multi fidelity
data fusion to reduce the number of high fidelity
evaluations to improve the efficiency of the
offline stage. And also we tried domain liquidation
for accelerations in large scale problems.
As I already mentioned, the regression tool
we used was called from process emulation
or Gaussian process regression. Just in case
you are not very familiar with this tool.
Generally speaking, in Gaussian process regression,
we assume the prior on the regression function
to be a Gaussian process with a given kernel
function perhaps also corrupted by additive
white noise conditioned on the training data
of the input output pairs we can resort to
a conditional Gaussian and have the posterior
distribution also as a Gaussian process with
the new mean function like this and the new
covariance function. And in this case, for
our regression function, you have predictive
sense we not only have a mean estimate, but
also have the posterior variance providing
us with certain some kind of uncertainty quantification
as a confidence level. And you're there to
determine hyper parameters inside a The Gaussian
process emulation and we can use empirical
Bayes method such as maximizing the marginal
likelihood. And on the other hand Gaussian
process regression is a kernel method, the
posterior mean estimation is actually equivalent
to the result of a kernel ridge regression.
This means we can also examine the results
of Gaussian process regression from the perspective
of reproducing kernel hyperspace. Yeah, yeah
analysis sentence. A side note about this
actually, deep learning or neural networks
also have a connections with Gaussian processes.
under certain assumptions, Bayesian neural
networks can be viewed as Gaussian processes
with specifically defined kernels. And as
I just mentioned, the government process regression
it has close connections to kernel ridge regression
and kernel ridge regression is actually a
function approximation inside reproducing
kernel Hilbert spaces a class of certain reproducing
kernel Hilbert spaces will form parents space
and the parents space is actually a proper
function space where we can investigate the
approximation properties of neural networks.
So, in this sense, we have a loop connecting
the probabilistic viewpoints and analysis
viewpoints of neural networks and the governance
processes. Right and I believe out of this
loop, there can be a lot of interesting results
and observations to be explored and discovered.
Okay, back to our model reduction game, we
have applied our Gaussian process based reduce
all the models reduced or the surrogate models
see a variety of applications including those
in computational mechanics like nonlinear
structural analysis, nonlinear solid mechanics,
as well as fluid dynamics and the fluid structure
interaction. And the more recently we have
been using our reducer the surrogate models
in forward and reverse UQ basically, with
our simulation, three online evaluations through
the Gaussian process surrogates we can generate
however many however, many samples we need
in UQ estimates, if we can have a good control
of our data driven reduce all the models the
bias in the uncertainty estimate would not
be so large either okay. So, this is our first
part using Gaussian processes for surrogate
modeling in the reduced order sense. So, this
is a valid option for many applications, because
the target modeling task is very easy to implement,
and it can work for many scenarios, but I
have to admit that surrogate modeling has
its limitations is actually has limitations
in predictive performance, because the Gaussian
process surrogates are only trying to approximate
trying to approximate or reduce other solutions
instead of trying to discover or trying to
represent the dynamics underlying the data.
And on the other hand, a surrogate modeling
can handle very well the interpolation of
the reduced demand of the solution manifold
over the parametric variation, but if we want
to predict for the future states it will have
a lot of limitations.
From another viewpoints. In reality, we do
we also do not always have full solution vectors
as our data right we may have other forms
of observations such as images, photos, video
and so on and other types of indirect data
as our data base and how do we how can we
lower reduce order low dimensional dynamics
out of these kinds of data is also a question
we need to think about. Combining this source
introduces my second method for today it is
reduce order the Renko representation out
of image data with deep kernel learning. And
in this work, our research question was a
little bit different. We try to learn low
dimensional latent dynamics from high dimensional
measurements given by image data, and these
images are often corrupted by significant
noise. Since the noise is a lot of noise has
been introduced with a specially need new
cue You're right. So, we are going to use
probabilistic machine learning tools for the
data driven discovery and as done in the quantification,
and here you can see an example, we have a
pendulum swinging back and forth, and we take
photos of central motion, and the way we can
try to learn the dynamical representation
in a low dimensional manner out of this image
data and this image data also corrupted by
noise, the probabilistic machine learning
tool we are going to use to address this is
called Deep kernel learning. In fact, the
kernel learning is a special type of manifold
Gaussian process in the sense that the manifold
embedded into the Gulf and process kernel
is simply a neural network and with the with
the structure setting, the Gaussian process
can take high dimensional data for example,
images as inputs, and in this sense, we can
partially overcome the curse of dimensionality
existing in Gaussian process emulation. And
in this case, we also have our neural network
parameters trained as Gaussian process hyper
parameters. And I would also like to note
that the training was such a deep learning
model is much simpler and cheaper than classical
Bayesian neural networks, okay, how should
we use deep learning to discover low dimensional
dynamical models, so, still we are going to
follow the idea of the three R's right remember
reduce, represent and and recover and we have
the high dimensional noisy image data as our
inputs, right we put them into our encoder
to reduce the dimensionality and nonlinearly
and then we have the low dimensional latent
space layer and the latent states right and
then we try to do representation and in this
work, we are simply we are simply using a
multi layer neural network to approximate
the map between the current reduced state
and the current external action to the next
reduce the state basically, this neural network
is trying to approximate a forward Euler scheme
right and after this, we use a decoder to
recover back to the images, I would like to
emphasize that we have the outer encoder and
the multi layer neural network for the dynamic
model both as deep kernel learning models
basically, were embedding a convolutional
neural network here and a multi layer neural
network here into Gaussian processes to enable
uncertainty quantification. In this case,
both the uncertainties in the encoding and
the uncertainties in the dynamical approximation
would be covered by the deep kernel learning
models and we together with all these three
modules in this big model, we train them together
and try to test how we can handle extracting
dynamical systems out of high dimensional
image data. Okay, we did several tests, several
tests, we added noise directly onto the image
data and we also try to try to add noise to
the external control or external actions or
even we add noise to the underlying dynamics
to make this system stochastic. And in all
these cases, our our model gave us very clear
and the compact representations of the low
dimensional dynamics and also I would like
to emphasize that we have very clear de noising
effect in the risk Reconstructor images okay.
So, this is I call this the gray box model,
because it is not black box and we are we
are having this deep kernel learning model
in the representation step to approximate
a fold older scheme. So, it is trying to approximate
certain dynamical structure underlying our
images right. So, this is a gray box, but
still we would like to think whether we can
incorporate more physics into the training
process to get more physically consistent
reduction out of out of the data. This will
introduce our third method that we are going
to discuss today is using Bayesian inference
to read or to estimate the reduced order operators.
Okay. So, we can start with an example suppose
you are trying to solve whiskers burgers equation,
you can use your favorite spatial discretization
for whiskers burgers equation for example,
you can use finite difference finite difference
over space or finite volume finite elements,
whichever works for spatial discretization.
And after the after this step we will end
up with a dynamical system in the full order
sense, which is quadratic, right because the
whiskers burgers equation is a quadratic.
We also know that if we have a linear reduced
basis, once we have projected the full order
system onto the linear reduce the space, we
will also we will end up with a reduced order
system being in the same formulation of a
quadratic structure only much reduced the
size. So, the quadratic, the polynomial structure
of the governing equation will still preserved
will only have a reduced dimensionality. If
we recall how we do this in nine intrusive
model reduction, actually, we have to get
the access to the code to the full order code
to get the matrix is a H, B and the vector
C and then formulate a reduce all the systems
through numerical projection and get the reduced
order operators he had, he had we had hundreds
and c hat, right. And this is not something
we want to do because that's intrusive, we
may not have the access in insights for other
code. That means, we do not exactly know about
the four odd operators ah B and C. But still,
we know that the reducer the systems through
linear projection would would follow a quadratic
formulation. So, we need a way to an alternative
way to figure out to estimate our reduced
order parameters, I had H hat behind and c
hat. Actually, the way we are resorting to
is called data driven reduced order operator
inference. And the idea is like following.
So, first of all, we gather our full order
data for the full for the full size vectors,
full size snapshots queue together the data
of q, then we use pod to compress our reduce
spaces, we then we read we we project our
Q data onto the V basis to get our reduced
the data for Q hat right. And then we plug
our q hat data into our reduced the order
system formulation. And then we try to minimize
the residual sum of squares for the for the
further reduce or the system by minimizing
such as squared the residual we are going
to have an estimate of the reducer the operators
a had H hat be had and c hat that best match
our q hat data reduce the data in the minimum
residual sense of course, and in the end of
the day, at the end of the day, we will have
a least squares problem and of course, you
can add your
your favorite regularization as necessary
to improve as as necessary to improve the
estimate of our reduced order reduce order
operators okay. So, this is a data driven
learning process. And of course, we may introduce
a variety of uncertainties inside this throughout
this process for example, we may have noise
in the data of the for the queue, and after
the reduction, the noise will be reduced a
little bit as well, but still they make exists
noise in the reduced the state data as well
in Q hat. On the other hand, as you can see
here, we need to approximate time derivatives
to get time derivative data in this loss function.
That means we have to perform for example,
finite differences to evaluate this to approximate
this time derivatives out of our data data.
And this is going to be introduced approximation
error which is another source of uncertainty
our data driven learning process. Also we
use the regularization and this is another
source of uncertainty. And last but not least,
we may have model Miss specification for example,
if your underlying system for your data is
actually a third order system with a minor
third order term, but now we are assuming
that the system is quadratic and the ignoring
sort of the term we have a model Miss specification
here, right. So, these are these are many
sources of the uncertainties that may be introduced
into this operator inference framework. This
is why we want to do uncertainty quantification,
we want to upgrade our deterministic or point
estimate into a Bayesian inference, so, that
we not only have a point estimate of our reduced
or the upper operators, but also a posterior
distribution to describe the quantified uncertainties.
Okay. So, we started with a very simple setup,
first of all, we define the residual of our
reduced order system as Gaussian type noise.
In addition to that, we also define our prior
on the reducer the operators as Gaussian joint
Gaussian distribution with predefined mean
vector and hyper parameters and variance.
The naturally we resort to the Bayes rule
and have the posterior distribution for our
reduce other operators with a new mean vector
and a covariance matrix. So, if we look closer
at the posterior mean vector, we will see
that this is actually equivalent to a deterministic
least squares estimate with with Tikhonov
Regularization or the estimators read regression
as this is a common sense in Bayesian version
of well known result. And in fact, in practice,
we often need such a teaspoon of regularizer
in our operating inference, because first
of all, it may resolve the issues will you
condition the grant matrix D transpose D here,
if this d transpose d is your condition, we
do need such a regularizer to improve the
condition number because we have to invert
this matrix right. And in some other cases,
we may also need a tuple of regularizer to
help stabilize the reduce all the time integration
afterwards. But, even though But, even even
we have such useful people of regularization,
we are still introducing extra uncertainties
into the operator inference process, right
we want to do quantify, do the quantification
of uncertainties for the use of taken off
regularizes. Actually, if we can recall, as
a token of regularizer is corresponding to
the prior of our Bayesian inference, that
means, is the definition of the penalty coefficient
for the regularizer is equivalent to choosing
a good prior for reduce all the operators.
So, that means, the quantifying the model
Yeah, certainties introduced by the pupil
of regularization is naturally covered by
such a Bayesian framework. Right. And in this
case, since we have a connection between the
regularization true thing, and the prior to
saying we can also use the perspective from
both statistical learning and the physics
based simulation to help us do the hyper parameter
learning. So, after we have the inference
for our reduced order operators, we can sample
we can sample over this posterior distribution
of these parameters, and have a lot of samples
individually and for each and every time we
can evaluate the reducer the dynamics not
only trying to reconstruct the history, but
also predict for the future states and we
have an ensemble of reducer other solutions,
then we can have the statistics of such probabilistic
reduce all the solution. We have tested this
method in several numerical examples. I'm
going to show you one here, this is the to
the single injector combustion process, right?
It's rather complex physics into the we have
fuel and oxidizer coming into coming into
the tube from the left hand side and the chemical
reaction will take place inside the tube,
right and we were trying to use our basic
operator inference to have a low dimensional
dynamical representation of this system. As
you can see, from both the first six pod moles,
and also for the x velocity at four critical
locations, in terms of accuracy, we have the
predictive mean quite close to the underlying
reference, not only for the reconstruction
Have the history data covered by the training,
but also for the future states future states
for quite long time. And in terms of uncertainty
quantification, we can see that both the errors
in the mean prediction and the uncertainty
band increasing similar way. So, this means
that the confidence level is giving us meaningful
indication about how uncertainties are propagated
from the estimates of the reduce or the operators
to the time integration over time. Okay. Maybe
you have already realized when we did the
Bayesian inference, we
explicitly involve the time derivative data
and it is often the case that we do not have
direct access to time the Rhodes's that means,
we often need to use numerical differentiation
for example, finite differences to approximate
time derivatives from the reduced the state
data and this can work if the data are perfect,
but what if we have noisy or scarce data right
in those cases, they find an element approximations
of the time derivatives would be very bad
and this will further compromise the quality
of our operator inference. You may say that
okay, I know neuro OD is right. In neural
ODEE treatment, we are directly incorporating
time integration into the loss function with
directly we directly compare the integrated
states to the state data, basically, we are
translating a differentiation into integration.
And then we use either a joint state or automatic
differentiation depending on which type of
time integration either appropriate either
discrete or continuous use, but this artist
means extra efforts in the training stage.
So more recently, together with some of our
collaborators, we have been trying to figure
out a simple way to address this issue. So
basically, what we want to improve the the
predictiveness when data are noisy and or
scares, basically when finite difference can
not really approximate to the time derivatives.
And here we are thinking about a more generic
setup for dynamical systems. Here I'm writing
a dynamical system right and each and every
line of the equation is is parameterised on
the left hand side. So in this case, the learning
of the dynamical system from the data is basically
posed as a Bayesian inference problem to estimate
theta i for each and every equation, each
and every patient in that dynamical system.
Okay, so, we want to figure out a way to conveniently
do this Bayesian inference without using finite
difference or other numerical approximations
of the time derivatives. So, this is our goal.
And of course, if you consider this app I
on the right hand side as a quadratic structure,
and this theta is our reducer, the operators
and each x i is a reduce the stage in the
reduce the system. So basically, this system
is going to be representing our reduced order
system in the in the last couple of slides,
but here we are considering a more generic
setup. So here we are going to, again, use
Gaussian process to help us the assumption
is that each and every state variable over
time is a Gaussian process. And it's well
known in the Gaussian process community that
linear operations on Gaussian processes will
not really change the government property.
So linear operations or government process
will remain Gaussian. That means the joint
distribution between the state which is governed
process and its time derivative will follow
a vector valued Gaussian process, we just
need to act the time derivatives add the proper
locations in the kernels. Okay? And then we
can use this to help us define a new likelihood.
Okay, so let's recall what the likelihood
is. So likelihood is the probability of certain
evidence like observations, data measurements
or other types of measurements given the parameters
we want to estimate right. So this is the
lag Through the function of our parameters.
So let's consider what kind of evidence we
can have in this scenario. So first of all,
we have the time series data in the data driven
sense, right? This is for Gaussian process
regression, we have the data, so we can do
emulation. And actually, we have another sort
of evidence in this setup, it is actually
the formulation of our differential equations.
So we can use the differential equation constraints
given in this form as additional evidence
to be incorporated into our likelihood. As
we just discussed, the joint distribution
of the date and time derivative will follow,
again, a Gaussian process, and we can use
this Gaussian process, this new joint Gaussian
process to define our joint likelihood, we
just need to replace the right hand side of
the dynamical system to we just need to use
the right hand side of our dynamical system
to replace the time derivative. And in this
case, we are trying to match the left hand
side and the right hand side of the dynamical
system together. And in this sense, we are
incorporating differential equations, constraints
into the definition of our likelihood. Okay,
so this is how we define our likelihood in
a new way. And of course, in the end of end
of the day, we are going to have a Bayesian
inference. Again, we have the prior as a joint
normal distribution, and the newly likelihood
as in the last slide, and then we have the
posterior once we have the posterior distribution
for the parameters theta i, we can have a
Bayesian predictions by sampling over such
a posterior theta i, right. So actually, we
can look more carefully at how our posterior
distributions for for our parameters actually
rearrange a little bit. The formulation of
our post posterior distribution for theta
i As you can see here, the maximum opposed
to ra ma P estimate of our theta i is actually
equivalent to our estimator through generalized
least squares regularized by our Tikhonov
regularizer again, and in the generalized
least squares formulation here, the target
term d hat here is actually the mean estimate
of our time derivatives through our Gaussian
process emulation, and the weight matrix in
our generalized least squares is actually
the covariance matrix for the estimated time
derivatives, so GP. So in this sense, it means
we are implicitly still trying to approximate
time derivatives, but this approximation of
the time derivatives is through the smooth
thing by a Gaussian process, emulation, and
more importantly, the uncertainties introduced
the introduced devices, a smooth learning
process is automatically covered automatically
included in such a Bayesian inference framework.
So, in the end of the day, we have an estimate,
if you have we have our estimates that covered
all the uncertainties involved in this in
this learning process. That means if you have
scars or noisy data, but you have a very good
Gulf from process, you can be relaxed, and
the Gaussian process will help you to analyze
the data and give you a very good implicit
estimation of the time derivative and using
Fletcher time derivative estimation, you can
have a good estimate of your reduced order
operators or the parameters in the dynamical
system. We have tested as this method in a
few examples. This is still ongoing work,
but I would like to share with you some of
our preliminary results. So first example
here is a locker Volterra system. We are going
to estimate the alpha, beta, delta and gamma
for as for a parameters in this system, using
our newly defined likelihoods through Gaussian
processes. As you can see here, when we when
we have no noise in the system, if we use
either a lot of data or much reduced amount
of data,
the results are all very good, very decent.
And then we've tried to make it more challenging.
We increase the noise level to 10%. As you
can see if we use all Other data we have results
are still good 10% of the data used quite
nice and 5% of the data, there could be some
error, but the trend is still good, then we
try to make it even more challenging, we increase
the level noise level to 20% with all of the
data still good results 10% of the data, reasonable
5% of the data to error becomes larger and
larger. But in the back to the end, we can
see that our method is quite robust with respect
to noise level and under sparse data, right,
you can make it more and more challenging,
and the method can still handle quite challenging
cases. And how about we consider reduce all
the modeling, and here I'm showing you a very
simple case is a heat equation linear equation
right and reduce all the model structure is
is linear, right? Right. And we want to do
the estimate of our reduced reduced order
parameters a had B hat and c hat here, right.
And as you can see, we can when we have quite
some noise in the in the full order stage,
once we use our newly defined Gaussian process
base likelihood, we can have a very decent
estimate of the reducer the system, once we
recover back to the full order size, even
at low point wise, local points, we can still
extract reasonable dynamical behavior out
of the noisy data, right, and not only to
in the, in the reconstruction of the history,
but also for the predictions for the future
states. And what if we reduce the number of
data still, as you can see, the results are
very good. So seems like Gaussian process
are very good at denoising. And this can help
us define go around, go around the derivative,
derivative difficulty, the relative difficulty
in the in the in the time series when the
data and noise or or scars and this can give
us very good results. In terms of in terms
of predictions. So still, these are some very
recent results. And I would like to hear some
of your ideas or opinions or suggestions.
And I guess this is about what I want to share
with you today. A few words as a summary of
some take home information. So today, we have
been discussing several different types of
model reduction techniques, you know, probabilistic
sense using probabilistic machine learning
methods, as the first one was about black
box method using Gaussian process surrogate
modeling. And the second one was that gray
box using deep learning to represent a low
dimensional dynamical systems out of noisy
images. And the third insert method was Bayesian
operator inference, basically, using Bayesian
inference to estimate reduce all the operators
with known physical structures. And in the
end, we discussed the how to use Gaussian
processes to incorporate differential equation
constraints into the likelihood definition
so that we can improve the predictive needs,
especially when the data are noisy or parts.
Okay, thank you very much. And I look forward
to your comments are greeted them suggestions
and discussions.
Thank you. Good. Thank you. Thank you so much
for the wonderful talk memo. I enjoyed it
a lot. Let's have a q&a sessions. All right.
Kevin, has a question in chat room. Yeah,
I will. We will, you know, keep a chance.
After this is asking in slides 1516 1516.
Okay, and what is the Yeah.
He's asking what is the last function to train
neural network and GT hyper parameters? Thank
you very much. Thank you very much. It
is a very good question, because the last
function was too long. So I didn't put it
here. We train this three models all together.
So we have to combine the last functions for
this the three parts all together. So I can
I can tell you what they are. And of course,
you can refer to the paper to see more details.
So first of all, we need to make sure that
the encoding decoding is making sense, right.
So we need the MS e two to match the reconstruction
of the encoding decoding. This is one second
one. We have to make sure this up oxygenation
of the for the older is making sense. So,
we have MSE for this multi layer perception
as well, this is the second one, the third
one will start to train the Gulf and processes
right? How to Train government process hyper
parameter basically, you can use maximum marginal
likelihood or the minimum of negative log
marginal likelihood, right, we have done we
have to incorporate the negative log marginal
likelihood of all this Gaussian processes
into the loss function. And the in the end,
we have to use variational inference to estimate
the probability. Right. So, the we also need
to use elbow to to replace the KL divergence.
So, all these terms will be combined together
for the training of this big model. And also
feel free to refer to the, to the paper for
more details, but this was roughly the spirit.
Yeah.
Okay. So one has a second question. If you
can go to slide 19. Yeah. This Bayesian inference
is based on a prescribed reduced model, with
uncertainty model parameters. That was your
Bayesian inference, quantify the model Miss
specification, for example, missing high order
or exponential times, etc.
Thank you. This
is definitely a very good question. And we
have been thinking about this question as
well. So of course, in our very first work,
we simply use the independent white noise,
right. And it was not really covering the
model Miss specification. And of course, you
can upgrade a little bit. And you can use
a Gaussian process to replace a white noise
for this error term. So basically, that's
going that's basically trying to approximate
your model Miss specification or your closure
as a Gaussian process target, you can do that.
But that's still limited. We are still trying
to figure out better ways to do to do it.
But based on structural framework, the best
thing you can do is to try to use the Gaussian
process to approximate this absolute AI as
a surrogate model for the closure.
All right, yeah. Thank you. I think next one
was rip up your hand people. So if you can
unmute yourself and ask questions. That'll
be awesome. Please, can you hear me? Yeah.
Yeah.
Thank you so much. Amazing. prospection. So
you touched upon extracting the basis, using
God the Gaussian processes or not? Yeah. So
say, for example, I have a snapshot matrix
has a million by million data points, where
you can't do D transpose D, I think you're
doing D transpose D to reduce the dimension
of the matrix to extract the pre processing,
or pod Moodstruck. So I just need your opinion
on the safer example, you have a million by
million data points in your snapshot matrix
where you can't do the transpose see, what
is the viable pre processing tool to go for
like a team or PCA? If you're using some some
conventional ones, it's gonna take a long
time to get those bases or integrations point
out. So what's your take on this when you
have 1,000,005 million data points or something
like?
Okay, thank you for your question. And let
me repeat your question and see I'm understanding
correctly okay. So, you have a lot of data
points. So that means this D D matrix will
be narrow, but very long, right? So, D transpose
D is the computational cost is very large.
And how do you deal with this? Okay, thank
you. We haven't we haven't met such a difficulty
yet. But I have some ideas how to deal with
this. So for example, you don't need all of
them to to estimate your reduce auto or the
operators right you can take one snapshot
among several right I read like 100 steps,
you can take one if that can still give you
a good estimate, why not write or you can
use some other techniques. For example, you
can use a bootstrapping or ensemble to have
so each time you only have a subset of the
samples and have an estimate and you do this
several times to form an ensemble and have
a more probabilistic estimate of your reduced
operators. This is this is another strategy
I can think of and actually in In sim D, they
have already they have already began to use
bootstrapping an ensemble to deal with this.
Another strategy is actually our our new method
here, right? You can simply reduce the number
of data and the lead Gaussian process to help
you interpolate and extrapolate to interpolate
to interpolate in this case. Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you so much for sharing.
Oh, look into those texts.
Listening to that reply, I was simply curious,
why can't you just use the HPC? Like, distributed
those data and then do the D transpose D?
Yeah, that could also be an option. Yeah.
Okay. All right. Next question from John,
have you tried or compared against other system
identification methods like, oh, kid, Moe
SPI? I don't even know how to pronounce it.
Most most, I
can tell you Sorry, I used to not call him
into. So observer Carmen face filter identification,
and multivariate output a whole state space?
Well, are you aware of that manual?
Authority? Maybe I have limited knowledge
to address this. But I have a comment I can,
I can, I can provide that basically, our method
here, for example, for this Gaussian process,
likelihood definition method, this can be
embedded into a lot of methods, right? This
is just a new way to define a likelihood.
If you are you, wherever you need likelihood,
you may think whether this likelihood can
be used in your favorite method, right? For
example, we can use this likelihood in operating
inference like I did before, or you can use
the similarity define the likelihood in Cindy,
right? It's also it's also option. So I would
say that our Gaussian process based likelihood
definition is more like a plugin, right? You
can use this to plug that you can plug this
into your inference framework if it is okay
to use. Yeah, this is a comment I can I can
provide. And of course, feel free to write
me an email about your specific considerations.
And I'm happy to discuss.
Okay, yeah. For example, will you go at Mark
tech next week? I'll be there. Yeah, let's
see. Where?
March 10 2020 20 in Paris.
I'm sorry. I'm not I'm not I'm not going I
guess.
Okay. Yeah, no worries. Thanks for joining
me. Yeah, yeah, we
wrote email before, right. So I know emails,
let's communicate. That's why
we need emails in the past. Thank you so much
for your great presentation.
Thank you.
Thank you. Awesome. Awesome. Can I ask question?
Sure. All right. So you met. One time in your
presentation, you mentioned that deep corner
learning training cost is less than patient
neural network. I can see that because the
Bayesian neural network is really, really
expensive to train. But I see that deep cone
of learning still has the component of neural
network and it is combined with the GP later
on. So the training of the DKL, the deep corner
learning, it should be as as expensive as
just training the normal neural network. Yeah.
Yeah, I think so. I think so. It's the Indeed,
indeed, we, for example, we use a maximum
marginal likelihood to train this manifold
GP. So basically, that's comparable to the
training of a deterministic neural network,
but but we different loss function. So this
is cheaper than the training of a Bayesian
neural network. Okay, let's it's a conditional
cause it is saved in this sense. I
see. Yeah. But, you know, the deterministic
neural network training of that is not an
easy task as you increase the data size, cause
you have to solve that normally. That's true.
That's true. So you still have an issue of
scaling. In that sense, I would admit,
yes, yes. Yeah. Because of the neural network
existing existing in this model. Yeah.
Right. Right. But, I mean, you know, other
compression techniques. I mean, a lot of times,
you know, you presented three or four different
methods, I think two or three weeks As you
know, based on the pod Media Composer because
we like it, we really like it, because the
training of that is, you know, very, a lot
less complex than training the neural network,
but it has disadvantages like it cannot accurately
represent the attraction dynamics, for example,
what the komak comment is, yeah, it became
decaying slow. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. But in essence,
in essence, deep corner learning would be
beneficial, because you're using the neural
network to compress. Yeah, and comments on
that,
I have very mixed feeling. My work I do use
the auto encoder or similar tools for nonlinear
manifold learning, because they are useful
and popular, of course. But, for example,
if you use that in convolutional auto encoder
here, you don't have as good as as good error
control as in pod, right? Many things are
unknown. And if you want to do more physically
meaningful projection onto the nonlinear latent
space, of course, you can do you can do least
squares, Petrov, Galerkin. That's one way.
So I guess you also notice that very well.
Yeah, that's one way. But it's not how it's
convenient, either. Especially when your neural
network, the encoder is very, very complex,
the projection to be very tricky. And if we
do blackbox learning, or, or we call a black
box, or green box learning, we are missing
some physics. So I have mixed feelings about
it. So if we have linear PCA, we can do the
linear projection here a very decent way.
Of course, it's not the best way. But basically,
we have to come up with a compromise either
here or that or that maybe you want the one
in the audience, commerce, commerce as with
with a very good idea, and maybe that can
be relevant revolution. Yeah, revolutionary?
Yeah. I don't have a clear answer for that
yet.
I don't think anyone has a clear answer. I
think I asked you a difficult question. I
love the, you know, your method of dealing
with noisy data, basically, using the sky
vision process to smooth those data and then
get the lowest accuracy. I saw in experiments,
you you try it up to 10% noise level? Yeah.
Have you tried to increase the noise level?
Like maybe 100% noise level?
Yeah, I showed. We also tried a little bit
more 30%. But that's not going to work. Gonna
work very well. So here is this is how we
roughly do is bind the level of noise, basically.
So so we enrich the solution data to get a
rough order of magnitude of the solution data.
And we So 10% means that 10% of that, right?
These are standard deviation for the white
now as we add onto the under the data. So
in that sense, if we increase to 100% data,
I'm not really making sense that all right,
yeah. So this is 20 30% would already be quite,
quite large. And the reality even though we
have data in the real word, sensing system,
that it wouldn't be so, so large, right? It
introduced some error, but the the level is,
is up to some limit.
Okay, so 20% If you think it's a reasonable
number
30% will be reasonable.
Okay, sounds good. We actually have a recent
work is about to be published is we're introducing
another way of dealing with those noisy data
as well using Gaussian process, but also,
but we are using too big Cindy like integral
integral integral form of the you know, sparse
identification of
Yeah. Basically, you have your PDS and you
have a weight you have a test functions and
do partial integration by part, so that the
noise will come from this counterpart to the
other one. Yeah,
exactly, but we use the weeks in the in the
latent space. So so we do the compression
first like either pod or auto encoder, and
then apply the weeks in the in the latent
space with this space. There when we apply
the noise level like up to 50% even like higher.
We got remarkable accuracy, very surprising
accuracy. So I will definitely Let's share
it with you.
Thank you, that will be very, very, very helpful.
But I do actually have a question for that.
So if you use the week, Cindy's very critical,
how to choose the test of functions, right?
Right, right,
we use a piecewise. The compactly supported
the basis functions. And it is sensitive to
how we change the radius, like the width of
that compactness. So you have to tune for
that, depending on the applications. Yeah,
that's my impression, too, is very good to
have this confirmed.
Thank you. Thank you. Yeah.
Maybe last question from me. So you show the
2d single injector complete combustion process?
Yeah. If you can go to that slide. I don't
know the slide number. Yeah. Yeah, what what
is Y here? y one, y two y three y four y,
which? So in the definition of Q of z vector
is a fractions of the, the fractions of the
so it's a two phase flow.
Awesome. Awesome. Yeah. It's a fraction of
the of the components. Yeah.
Like the volume fraction.
That's great. And you apply that to you use
the pod? Yeah, we did the pod. Yes. Yeah,
this is complicated. Yes, this is indeed a
case where pod may not be the best, the best
choice, but we use a lot of building models
in the end to guarantees approximation is
still decent.
I mean, you're doing extrapolation to like
in
extrapolation to we use the 60 ish pod models,
if I remember correctly, I have to refer to
the paper to to refresh my memory, but we
use the indeed use a lot of pod mouths. Okay,
awesome.
I loved it. So I think we need to talk about
this. Yeah. All right. Any other questions
from audience? If not, let's thank our speaker,
Mango for the wonderful talk. And, you know,
all the nice researcher he presented. Thank
you so much. Thank
you. Thank you for the invitation, the other
nice discussions and Communications. Thank
you. Awesome.
Let me push the start button.